you
want me to drive
house
is
[Laughter]
um
okay well
[Music]
okay
um
hey brian can you do a football check
for him
okay okay never mind they're good
thank you
oh
like that
laughs
okay
oh
hey
uh
right
and melissa good afternoon by exactly
which authority the president would be
able to do it but the president as you
mentioned
threatening to withhold federal funds
from certain cities targeting
seattle portland new york city and
washington dc
directing federal agencies to look at
what funds might be
withheld if these cities give you more
to combat the lawlessness
in part that memorandum reading quote
the trump administration will hold
lawless jurisdictions accountable
by reviewing federal funds provided to
them restricting their eligibility for
certain federal grants were permissible
and working to direct those funds to
jurisdictions that protect communities
basically
taking from one city to another the
president stretched both federal funding
renewing his feud with the new york
governor andrew cuomo
in a press briefing last night cuomo
saying the president is not welcome
in new york city listen here
on twitter this morning saying governor
andrew cuomo of new york has the worst
record on death and china virus 11 000
people alone
died in nursing homes because of his
incompetence and this from the press
secretary kaylee mcadam this morning
that this is expected to come up with
the press briefing particularly by what
authority the president believes he can
withhold congressionally appropriated
funds
it's also my understanding melissa that
uh there will be a little fire
at the top of today's briefing as david
mcinerney expected
to take square aim at nancy pelosi over
what happened at that san francisco
salon in the last couple of days
well listen
thank you
all right
i know
she is
right
hmm
remember last year for six weeks
if it doesn't rain for six hours
last night
so
oh
thank you
he wasn't down
uh
mrs
[Music]
two minutes
oh
yes
so chris told me
okay
okay so ap is in the center is here
okay
oh
whatever
[Music]
good afternoon everyone two briefings
ago
i asked where is nancy pelosi
today i can announce we have found nancy
pelosi
as you can see we found nancy pelosi
going into her hair salon we will be
playing the video on loop for all of you
to see
during the duration of this introduction
nancy pelosi was not in the halls of
congress when i asked where she was she
was not working
in good faith to make a deal for the
american people
nope nancy pelosi was found in san
francisco at a hair salon
where she was indoors even though salons
in california
are not only open for outdoor service
apparently the rules do not apply to
speaker nancy pelosi
she wants small businesses to stay shut
down but only reopen
for her convenience do as i say not as i
do
says nancy pelosi nancy pelosi is
holding up 1.3 trillion dollars in
relief for the american people
while getting special access to the very
kind of small businesses
that this money would support businesses
like this hair salon
before she skipped town to violate her
state's health guidelines pelosi
proposed a bill
it was called the heroes act which
contained no additional paycheck
protection
funding this is funding that would help
with a very small business she has
bizarrely accused of plotting against
her
the president sees through democrats
disregard for americans in need and he
took
action unilaterally in his own accord he
provided relief from evictions he
provided unemployment insurance he
paused student loan payments
and he cut the payroll tax putting money
in the american people's pockets
congress also failed to authorize
funding to provide children with free
lunches for the 2020-2021 school year
and again president trump with senior
adviser ivanka trump took action
and now usda has extended a summer
program which will ensure
children continue to have access to free
meals through the end of the year
nancy pelosi is demanding an apology
from a single mother
and small business owner who has
received threats since nancy pelosi's
comments against her salon
salon owner erica kaya said this since
this happened i've received nothing but
hate text messages death threats
saying they're going to burn down my
hair salon it's just sad that my
community is pulling this saying that i
threw her under the bus when i did not
so that's hurtful but yes i think i'm
pretty much
done now nancy pelosi you ought to
apologize to the american people
or better yet come back to washington
and get to work
for hard-working americans like this
salon owner that you maligned and
demanded an apology from
and with that i'll take questions yes
john
kelly do you acknowledge that it is
illegal in this country to vote twice
in the same election are you referring
to the president's comments earlier
today
i'm just asking you a basic yes or no
question do you believe it is illegal
the president does not condone unlawful
voting uh the president's been very
clear about this some once again not
surprised the media is taking the
president out of context do you recall
what the president said on this matter
specifically i have it right here okay
maybe you should read it out for me then
okay so the the president said that you
should go to your fault you should vote
early
by mail and you should go either uh
early voting or day of and try to vote
again
so he is asking people to vote by mail
and then to go down to the polling place
on election day
and to vote again if their vote has if
they can't
confirm their voter's been counted
you're missing a very crucial line from
the president's remarks
if it is not tabulated meaning your
mail-in vote
then you will be able to vote in person
if it is not tabulated
this is why at least five states in this
country that they do not
count any mail-in votes until election
day
so those votes won't be counted until
afterwards
so that there's no way to know whether
or not they're voting there's a very
simple answer and this is how it works
first a lot of states have what are
called
electronic poll books and what this
means is that in real time this is
updated so if your vote is counted
they check the electronic poll book and
you will not be able to vote in person
because your vote has been counted
um there's a secondary situation so
those who do not have electronic poll
books
every single state in the country you
can cast a provisional ballot
and that is a ballot that is there and
if your your vote that you have not
mailed in is not counted
they will then count the provisional
ballot and that is exactly what the
president's
referring to but what democrats are
doing is saying this we want an entire
new system for voting one subject to
fraud
don't take it from me take it from jimmy
carter who said in 2005 as part of a
bipartisan commission absentee ballots
remain the largest source of potential
voter fraud
so what democrats want you to do is say
trust us
but don't verify don't verify that your
vote's been counted this president's
trying to enfranchise americans
which is exactly what he's been saying
he wants every american to have
a vote because he understands what jimmy
carter understood and what so many of
us understood until the president
started putting the focus on mail-in
voting
and that was this that it is subject to
fraud every vote should count and every
american should verify that their vote
is counted by going to their polling
to the executive director of the north
carolina board of electors who says
that this would be creating a big
problem on election day what i would say
is that the president has laid it out
very clearly you should verify your vote
and not only that i would appoint
them to the fact that in 2016 before we
tried this entire new system of mass
mail out voting
319 000 votes were not counted that were
cast by mail 319
000 in an election that came down really
to 80 000 votes in pennsylvania
wisconsin
in michigan that's untenable and
hundreds thousands more will not be
counted with the democrats fraudulent
mass bailout voting system
the president wants enfranchisement
plain and simple john can i ask you a
process and jurisdiction question the
president
uh signed a memorandum last night
directly federal agencies
to look at funds that might be withheld
to city as to cities that
do not do enough to restore a law in
order
by what authority does the president
believe he can do that
yeah the president um believes that what
we should do that the purpose of
government
um is to protect life liberty and
property that is the purpose
of the federal government and it's
imperative that the federal government
review
the use of funds by jurisdiction so what
this does this memo
it really does three things one it asks
federal agencies to detail all federal
funds
that are being provided to seattle
portland new york city and washington dc
secondly within 14 days the attorney
general will develop a list of
anarchist jurisdictions of lawlessness
zones
that are permitting violence and
destruction of property and then within
30 days
the white house budget director will
issue guidance to the heads of agencies
on restricting eligibility
of or otherwise disfavoring to the
maximum extent possible by law anarchist
jurisdictions and the receipt
of federal grants in south carolina the
dole
did note that you can withhold funding
so long as it pertains to the federal
program pertains uh to what you're
trying to incentivize
um so we believe here when you look at
new york a 177 percent increase in
shootings
um in seattle where there was a lawless
chop zone where two died in portland
where you've seen 140 officers injured
this is a dereliction of duty and if the
states will not act in their police
power and secure their streets
this president will use every lawful
mechanism available to him to try to
supplement their failures and in some
cases that's meant
federal officers in minneapolis and
kenosha where we've been invited
this is yet another attempt to make sure
no more children
like legend talifaro die on our streets
congressionally appropriated funds i i
expect that
you would expect there to be uh
immediate legal action taken leticia
james the attorney general for the state
of new york
warned uh a few minutes ago that if you
try to withhold any funds she will
immediately slap you with a lawsuit
well she's free to do that we believe
that what we will do will be lawful
within the bounds
of the law and we encourage states to
act and cities to act in the way that
kenosha and minneapolis did although be
it delayed
a little bit there they finally stepped
up and asked for federal support and
they got it because too many americans
are dying on our streets
too many businesses being burned to the
ground that's not the american way
uh by a long shot okay just to follow up
on that the president
as we know tried to withhold federal
money from sanctuary cities
and he lost as per the courts so why
isn't this
also doomed to fail i'm not going to get
ahead of exactly what the final product
will look like again i just walked you
through there's a 14-day timeline
for the doj and then a 30-day timeline
for office of management and budget but
we believe that we are on the right here
let me do a couple calls if i can so in
may the president said the u.s will be
designated antifa as a terrorist
organization yes or no did the president
do that
um what the doj said is that they would
be looking at antifa related charges in
the lens of domestic terrorists to be
clear they did not designate auntie for
them to be clear they will be pursuing
domestic terrorism charges against
antifa individuals anarchists who are
wreaking havoc across our country
and who uh the suspect at least in
portland killed an
innocent man out in portland uh just
over the weekend right for sure and then
in 20 but they didn't declare i'm a
terrorist organization as they said
he's pursuing domestic terror charges in
2017 he threatened to withhold federal
funds from uc berkeley if they did not
allow free speech has he done that
i have to i'll follow up with you on
that i guess the question is the
president makes
a lot of threats knowing that he's not
going to follow through or that they're
not
legal so is this what he's trying to do
here yet again no the president
will follow through his memo is
exceedingly clear
we are pursuing every avenue within the
federal government
to take care of the american people when
you have a one-year-old
being killed in new york when you have a
little beautiful girl in atlanta named
sequoia turner who lost our life
yes this federal government will do
everything within our lawful power
and yes the president is serious about
this can i follow up with one last one
if i can on walter reed the president
november said he went to walter reed to
begin his physical
he said he was there this week he said
he was there to complete his physical in
fact your predecessor
said the same back then that it was to
begin it so which one
was it when the president went to walter
reed the president did his physical and
two parts these are very extensive when
you're doing
a presidential physical and he used uh
the two visits to walter reed
to complete the physical and two stops
again the media is engaging in
conspiracy theories about the
president's health president
just to be clear you said he did in two
stops but he said he completed it this
week he said he was there to complete it
you're saying that's not true so his
statement
yes next question i'm not engaging in
conspiracy theories anymore
i'm just asking if he was correct please
no go ahead
um senator schumer came out with state
today
saying that too much of the evidence
points to the trump administration
pressuring the fda to approve a vaccine
by election day to boost his
reelection prospects can you assure the
american people
that if a vaccine does come out
before election day is approved before
election day that it is safe and
effective
and can you address his assertions that
you are pressuring the fda to come up
with the vaccine
before election no one is pressuring the
fda to do anything uh this is again a
bizarre theory spun up by cnn among
others let me
note that the fda you have dr hanu said
this
i can assure you 100 that the president
has never pressured me to make a
decision regarding
any regulatory aspect of the fda's work
he said that
just a few months ago it is absolutely
the case you had secretary azar saying
this morning
about the vaccine whether it's october
15th or november first or november 15th
this is all about saving lives um you've
had dr fauci
say we in fact briefed the president
today this was a few weeks ago about
this in the oval office i was there for
that briefing
and dr fauci said there is no political
pressure that i have seen
at all to move quickly this president
wants to break through regulatory
barriers to get a vaccine as safely as
to the
american people as quickly as possible
because lives are at stake
but he will not in any way sacrifice
safety
and making sure that this is 100
airtight before
on the american people receive it so the
priority here is saving lives
um safety and there will be a safe and
effective vaccine in the works and again
i think
the cnn spinning up this conspiracy
theory it always based upon
the cdc career brought this up yes and
cnn was peddling a theory
on this as well basically you had career
officials at the cdc
who made a decision who spoke with
states about distributing
vaccines we're preparing in advance to
have a safe and effective vaccine
distributed
because unlike the obama administration
during swine flu
they had real problems in that regard
the obama administration promised 100
million doses by october
they then reduced that number to 40
million for the swine flu by mid-october
when the demand for vaccine was at its
highest
supply fell dramatically short with as
few as 11 million doses on hand
you even had their cdc director saying
we are nowhere near where we thought
we'd be by now
we are not near where vaccine
manufacturers predicted we would be we
share the frustration of the people who
have waited
online or called a number or checked a
website and haven't been able to find a
place to get vaccinated
unlike the obama biden administration we
make plans in advance that's why we have
contracts for 100 millions
of vaccine production in advance and
it's why cdc
career officials have worked with all 50
states to make sure that we can
distribute this vaccine we do our
homework in advance unlike obama by
just another one so vice president joe
former vice president joe biden said uh
on
alexander's poisoning that the mode of
attack leaves no doubt
as to where the responsibility lies the
russian state
does the president agree with that
assessment and has he
made his uh voice known to
the russian government on this issue so
we're deeply troubled uh by the results
released yesterday
um alexi navalny's poisoning is
completely reprehensible
russia has used chemical nerve agents in
the past and we're working with their
allies and the international community
to hold those in russia accountable
wherever the evidence leads and restrict
funds for their malign activities um the
russian people have a right to express
their views peacefully without fear of
retribution of any kind
and certainly not with chemical agents
and no one has been tougher
on the russian government than this
president yeah thanks katelyn
on tick tock the president said that
that ban is going to take effect on
september 15th if the deal is not agreed
to
what will that look like is google and
apple gonna have to delete that app from
their app stores are
people gonna have to delete it off their
phones tell us what will happen on
september 15th if there's a deal
i'm not going to get a hat ahead of
announcing on those plans on sept
september 15th i know you had some
questions on the timing of everything
and i
i told the commerce department to be
expecting your call because they can
walk you through
you were had questions of the 45 day
time frame so i did get some clarity for
you on that if you follow up with me we
can get you in touch with the commerce
department okay
yeah okay i just wanted to ask you about
the investigation there's a couple of
uh contracts that were awarded that
peter navarro was involved with
one uh there's an investigation going on
in terms of the kodak
uh the money that went to kodak uh to
allow them
to develop pharmaceuticals there are
other contracts now for ventilators that
have received scrutiny
um can you give us an update on on how
concerned you are that maybe
some of these business deals are going
through too quickly you're not getting
enough scrutiny is there any particular
finding that you can offer at this point
on that
yes we've we've made many contracts
using the dpa 78 times 30 times with
regard to testing
we're very proud of what we've done of
course um if there are new allegations
with a given company we certainly look
at those and look at them closely
as we did with the kodak um situation
but we're very proud of what we've done
we were met with an unprecedented
challenge a novel coronavirus that came
to our shores from china
and we are very proud that our contracts
have enabled us to have
a very large and growing stockpile in
fact
we've rapidly increased the amount of
n95s
on hand to more than 60 million we're on
track to have 10 times more than pre
pandemic levels by the fall
um significantly surge the number of
gowns on hand to more than 27 million
and we have tremendous level of
ventilators on hand at 109
000 and we will have tens of thousands
more by the fall so the contracts we've
made have enabled enabled these numbers
among others i'm not even getting into
therapeutics like from death severe
uh but of course if there's ever
allegation we take it seriously and look
at it as we did with kodak confirm how
many
how many allegations of ron doing uh
that you're
looking at that i'm not aware of the one
or two that you named out of the many
many contracts that we've had
yes thanks kaylee the herd immunity
strategy for the pandemic has been
called dangerous by some experts and i'm
wondering if president trump has formed
an opinion on this concept
and if he thinks that that is an
achievable goal
yeah the herd immunity so-called theory
was something made up in the
fanciful minds of the media that was
never something
that was ever considered here at the
white house here at the white house what
we've done
is race to get a safe and effective
vaccine in record time but
we get it by the end of the year i will
far outpace
ebola which took 14 months to get to
phase three clinical trial three years
to get to completion this will be the
fastest
vaccine ever for a novel pathogen i'm
here at the white house we talk about
therapeutics and are very proud that
we've
identified we have more than 270
clinical trials 570 in the
planning stages and successful
therapeutics that we know of like
dexamethasone
um and rem de severe that's what we do
here at the white house um the hurt
immunity theory again
uh with something made up in the mind of
the media on the supreme court the
president
said that he would come out with a list
of candidates by september 1st when can
we expect to see that list
you will see it soon and certainly
within the next few weeks um but it will
be after the labor day weekend
thank you back on the cities how would
uh the president's
plan to reduce funding to cities
actually help
protect citizens that you said was the
goal of the president
now that is the goal and um what the
intent is
is to incentivize cities um to follow in
the way
of kenosha and minneapolis who when they
were in the midst of a situation that
they couldn't handle just at the local
level they requested federal assistance
and it worked within 24 hours you saw a
much different scene in kenosha within
24 hours
a much different scene in minneapolis so
we want states
uh to work with us and those two models
are examples of
democrats um who have done so on the
contrary you see a much different
situation
in new york and portland and dc and
seattle and some of the factors as noted
in the memo that will go into the
lawlessness assertion
are whether they've forbid police from
intervening
whether they've withdrawn law
enforcement protection from certain
areas like we saw
where a police precinct was abandoned in
the lawless chop zone in seattle
those are the types of changes and
behavior we want to see from cities
because protecting the citizenry
should be their uh paramount concern
thanks fairly
the government runs out of funding by
the end of the month is the white house
confident it can avoid another shutdown
and um is the president open to
including some of this coveted stimulus
as part of the cr
i haven't talked to him about um that
but we do believe that we'll be able to
get funding to avoid a shutdown are
negotiations underway now like
if you guys started talking to congress
about this yet i have to talk with the
chief i haven't talked to him
specifically about that but it we it has
been discussed internally i know at
least that
yes thanks haley can you give us a sense
um on the memo issue last night can you
give us more of a sense of the funding
that would be
under review and also why does the white
house believe that this is the right
time
to be considering restricting funding to
the first states were in the middle of
the pandemic
and there's some are dealing with
violence yeah again so first
the first part of your question it's
undergoing a review part of that
step one of this memo is for federal
agencies to detail the funds being
provided so
i can't give you a readout of exactly
which funds are being looked at until
that review
is conducted but why now why now because
in new york city you've seen a 177
increase in shootings in july
meanwhile you have the feckless
government of mayor de blasio and
governor cuomo
pulling 1 billion dollars with the b
from nypd at the same time we learned
that in a 28 day period arrests were
down in new york city
by 62 percent um the looting of 450
businesses that have been damaged in
seattle a lawless chop zone
where two died now is the right time
when you see numbers like this because
lives are at stake
and oftentimes the lives of innocent
little babies who should be here today
if democrat mayors got their act
together didn't cut funding from police
i did start arresting people and enforce
the laws yes
thanks uh the president and joe biden
are both going to be in
shanksville pa uh next friday
commemorate 9 11.
have you spoken to him about appearing
with the former vice president like he
did
with secretary clinton back in 2016 up
in new york
i have no details on for that upcoming
event but we are
intending to be in shanksville as well
okay and then just one more follow-up on
the cities
um again i know it's it's under review
has the president directed
director vaught to make sure that future
coronavirus age
is exempt from this this memorandum um i
don't see in what
universe that would be connected uh to
the issue at hand which is ensuring
lawfulness
or anything like that but again i don't
want to get into the specific funding
ahead of the review process that is
ongoing
yes are we all set okay there we go yeah
thank you facebook said earlier today
that he would be removing the post where
the president was talking
yesterday with a local reporter about
voting uh twice
if it's not corrected and if it doesn't
indicate that the president was
wrong in those assertions what what do
you have to say about
facebook's move on this post um you said
facebook designated a post i missed the
very first part
right they said that they would remove
the post from those profiles who
posted and do not say that the
what the assertions of the presidents
are wrong yeah i haven't seen the
particular post you're referring to but
the president
is crystal clear here that he only again
to read that part of his quote if your
vote isn't tabulated
then you'll be able to vote in person
this is about verifying that every vote
is counted because we know voters are
disenfranchised just in the 2020
presidential primary for instance there
were 100 000
ballots rejected in california mail-in
ballots in new york
one in five think about that one in five
mail-in ballots were rejected a total of
84 000 ballots rejected in new york city
alone and we know the thin margins by
which elections
are decided and we also know that as
research has shown
young black and hispanic voters are more
likely to have their mail-in ballots
rejected that's according to a
washington post article so the president
wants
enfranchisement not disenfranchisement
that's his goal
um with the comments that he made
yesterday if i may ask another one on
immigration please
okay the president had said that he will
be issuing another order in september do
you have any more
information on that when he may be
issuing that immigration order
yeah no updates on a forthcoming
immigration
thank you kenny uh if you mentioned role
model cities like kenosha
if say mayor de blasio and mayor bowser
for instance
if they were to this week take specific
actions
and uh and get some of the law order
back under control
would this memo continue to go forward
or would you continue to
uh propagate the plans listed in this
memo
we have to see a radical change in
behavior from the mayor of dc
who allowed a church to burn from the
mayor of portland
who stood with the protesters only to be
chased out of his own home
uh the windows shattered of his building
by the very protesters he deemed
peaceful who were actually anarchist
who took the life of a 39 year old man
this past
weekend but look when the local
government does an act we use
every avenue available to us at the
federal level
i mean that it pertains to this memo as
one example another example is operation
legend
which we're very proud of and have some
new numbers for you
on that since the operations launched
more than 2
000 arrests including 147 homicides have
been made
more than 544 firearms have been seized
um and more than those are illegal
weapons and more than seven kilos of
fentanyl 14 kilos of heroin 12 kilos of
cocaine
and 50 kilos of methamphetamine have
been seized
and of the individuals arrested 476 have
been charged
with federal offenses and there's a
detailed readout from doj
of each offense and the great work that
our federal law enforcement officials
have done
so thank you to our police thank you to
our federal law enforcement
you keep us safe when democrat mayors
and derelict governors do not
thank you can you say foreign
great job